begrüßen und darauf hinweisen
eingeschlagen meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren das gewicht lag schon länger
in der luft was über das ausland wahl
beeinflussen das dirty campaigning oder
geheimdienstlich gesteuerte aktionen zu
befürchten sind
man hat in der vergangenheit schon des
öfteren versucht nicht zu fall zu
bringen zum beispiel durch bewusst
gesteuerte falsche truppen gerichtet
durch versuche mich ins rechtsextreme
eck zu drängen und auf unterschiedlichen
ebenen zu diskreditieren
wir haben den letzten drei jahren viel
an verleumdungen und diffamierungen aber
auch an bösartigkeiten erleben müssen
was aber hier vor zwei jahren inszeniert
wurde habe eine völlig neue dimension
hier wurde in silberstein manier eine
schmutzkübel und desinformationskampagne
startet die an perfidie und auch an
niederträchtigkeit nicht zu übertreffen
ist
besonders übel war der vorwand unter dem
die beiden offensichtlich beauftragten
lockvögel noch ein containers
herangetreten sind denn kurz nach dem
tod seines vaters war emotional
angeschlagen war gaben sie vor sich für
ein jagdgebiet im besitz der familie zu
interessieren
die angeblich lettische eu
staatsbürgerin erzählt die mit ihrer
tochter nach wien zu ziehen und sind zu
wollen und in österreich fuß fassen zu
wollen und auch hier investitionen
setzen zu wollen
es war ihr ein anliegen nachdem sie
offenbar über monate hinweg mit johann
gudenus eine freundschaft eine
vertrauliche ebene sichergestellt hat
mit ihrem deutschen bekannten dirigenten
einmal dann in folge auch mich
kennenzulernen
ein diesbezügliches privates gespräch
fand dann vor zwei jahren nämlich im
jahr 2017 im sommer auf den besser start
im beisein ihres deutschen bekannten der
uns zu einem abendessen in einer machen
auch bekannt geworden ist einer
präparierten fink
eingeladen hatte mit illegalen mitteln
und methoden und der missbrauch von
video und abhörgeräte wurde versucht
gutes und mich zu straftaten zu
bestimmen beziehungsweise zu statements
zu verleiten die strafrechtlich
bedenklich sein könnten bzw durch
ausgewählte ausschnitte aus dem
gesamtkomplex gerissen sind uns gezielt
beschädigen sollten die dame habe ich
einmal an diesem besagten privaten
abendessen in meinem müller getroffen
danach nie wieder einen kontakt zu ihr
gehabt und nie wieder gesehen keine
spenden sind an die partei oder
gemeinnützige vereine ergangen von dem
gesagten namen die genannt wurden sind
und auch niemand anderer in der partei
hat er mit dieser dame und diesem
deutschen bekannten der dame kontakt wer
mich so ein rein privates treffen wo nur
wir beide diesen kontakt hatten
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
ich weiß genau dass ich im rahmen dieses
gespräches und das war ein abendessen
von 17 uhr bis nach mitternacht fast
sieben stunden dort verbracht habe und
im rahmen dieses gespräches immer wieder
penibel auf die einhaltung aller
gesetzlichen bestimmungen unseres
rechtsstaates bestanden habe und das
habe ich mehrmals deutlich und klar
betont und es gab und gibt bei mir keine
illegalen und rechtswidrigen vorgänger
auch keine handlung hat diesbezüglich
und so verlange ich natürlich auch die
herausgabe des gesamten rechtswidrig
erstellten videomaterials welche
letztlich auch belegen wird und nicht
nur die ausgewählten ausschnitte etwas
das auch genauso dort stattgefunden hat
in einem siebenstündigen privaten
gespräch in meinem urlaub wurde ich ja
unter ausnutzung einer zunehmenden
alkoholisierung und ja es war eine tolle
geschichte und ich war in einer intimen
atmosphäre verleitet auch unreflektiert
und mit lockerer zunge über alles und
jedes zu polemisieren und ja meine
äußerungen waren nüchtern gesehen
katastrophal und ausgesprochen beim
lesen ich stehe nicht an all jene um
entschuldigung zu bitten sich damit in
das kredit gebracht habe und mit meinen
unbedachten äußerungen auch gekränkt und
beleidigt habe und auch den jetzigen
bundeskanzler über den ich damals auch
um überprüfte schmutzige gerüchte auch
besprochen und gestreut hatte
es war ein typisch alkoholbedingt das
machogehabe mit dem ich ja
wahrscheinlich auch die attraktive
gastgeberin beeindrucken wollte und ich
habe mich frisch wie ein teenager
verhalten und eigentlich übersteigert
auch agiert und damit habe ich letztlich
den wichtigsten menschen in meinem leben
zutiefst verletzt nämlich meine frau und
lieber verliebt ich weiß dass du jetzt
du siehst und ich kann verstehen dass du
verletzt und enttäuscht bist und ich
hoffe du kannst mir verzeihen denn es
tut mir aufrichtig leid
ich möchte mich von ganzem herzen auch
mit dir entschuldigen
es erscheint mir aber auch wichtig zu
betonen dass mit diesem geheimen bild
und tonaufzeichnungen mehrfach straff
gesetzliche vorschriften verletzt worden
sind und dagegen verstoßen würde
genauso würde verstößen gegen den
ehrenkodex adresse und die
journalistische sorgfaltspflicht und die
berufsethik der einzige strafrechtlicher
verstoß der vorliegt ist diese
geheimdienstlich inszenierte lokhalle
mit illegalen aufzeichnungen wo man zwei
jahre zu gewartet hat um diese dann in
folge auch zu zünden und ja das war ein
gezieltes politisches attentat eine
auftragsarbeit
und wer geglaubt hat dass mit
silberstein schon das niederträchtige
niveau erreicht war
wird eines schlechteren belehrt und ich
frage mich ernsthaft wozu diese
gruppierungen und netzwerke mit ihrer
kriminellen energie noch zu allem fähig
sind
ich weiß sehr genau wie man es etwas
gesetzwidriges angeboten oder gemacht zu
haben und ich werde daher auch alle
rechtlichen schritte unternehmen sowohl
mit medienrechtlichen als auch
strafrechtlichen anzeigen und wir haben
einige indizien auch was mögliche
mittäter betrifft und die gegen mich
erhobenen vorwürfe mit eigenen wieder
zur verfügung stehenden mitteln zu
entkräften und gleichzeitig diejenigen
die mit wirklich kriminelle
machenschaften gegen mich vorgegangen
sind zu überführen
und ich frage mich wer diese netzwerke
sind und welche rolle auch der herr
böhme man in diesem zusammenhang spielt
aber dessen ungeachtet sage ich heute zu
mir aber auch zu ihnen
ja es war dumm es war unverantwortlich
und es war ein fehler und ich bin seit
14 jahren in meiner verantwortung partei
obmann der freiheitlichen partei und
seitdem habe ich gemeinsam mit meinen
weggefährten und mitstreitern in einer
landesgruppe der fpö durch konsequente
und nachhaltige arbeit zu einer größe
geführt in der wir alle uns ja alle
gemeinsam auf augenhöhe mit dem
koalitionspartner unsere politischen
inhalte umsetzen und denjenigen seiner
diese erfolgreiche regierungsarbeit
einfahren im auge ist möchte ich
keinesfalls auch nur irgendeinen vorwand
liefern
mein fehlverhalten als begründung zu
nehmen diese regierung zu fall zu
bringen
wenn die freiheitliche
regierungsbeteiligung bedeutet dass wir
in den ersten jahren fünf monaten hohe
verantwortung tragen mehr sicherheit
mehr geld für die pensionisten und für
die arbeitende bevölkerung und für die
familien sichergestellt haben und auch
sicherstellen eine steuerreform keine
schulden mehr
in unserem land den mitbürgern zu munden
ein strenges und konsequent das system
aber auch wenn es in der
integrationsfrage einiges los im
positiven sinn zu korrigieren ist die
richtigen entscheidungen auch
sichergestellt zu eurem kopftuchverbot
in den kindergärten und volksschulen
auch kampf gegen ich sage den
extremismus im allgemeinen aber auch den
politischen islam und dem antisemitismus
in unserer gesellschaft und eine
europapolitik die an österreichs
interessen orientiert ist und ja es gibt
noch viel zu tun denn wir wollen das
regierungsprogramm ja weiterhin umsetzen
und wir stehen zu diesem
regierungsprogramm in unserer gelebten
verantwortung für österreich und seine
bevölkerung und meine person darf aber
nicht der grund dafür sein dass zu
verunmöglichen und vielleicht einen
vorwand zu liefern
diese regierung zu sprengen denn das war
das ziel dieser rechtswidrig angelegten
akkordierten schmutzkübel aktion die
hier stattgefunden hat
und deshalb habe ich heute um 11 uhr ein
gespräch mit dem herrn bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz gehabt wo ich meinen
rücktritt von der funktion des
vizekanzlers der republik österreich
angeboten habe und er hat diese
entscheidung annehmen wird und das tue
ich in meiner verantwortung für dieses
projekt ist durch in meiner
verantwortung einen weiteren schaden vor
allen dingen auch von meiner familie
das ist das wichtigste im leben und von
meiner partei und dem amt auch
abzuwenden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ja
darüber hinaus werde ich am sonntag in
um das parteipräsidium eine übergabe als
bundesparteiobmann sicherstellen und
meine obmann funktion auch zurücklegen
werden in folge auch die weiteren kämen
auch in der landespartei einberufen und
die entsprechende schritte setzen und
die führung der partei angelegt hatten
wir ab sofort mein stellvertreter
norbert hofer auch übernehmen und
abschließend möchte ich mich aufrichtig
entschuldigen die ich in meinem
verhalten enttäuscht habe meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren denn natürlich
und das möchte ich auch gleichzeitig
betonen möchte ich mich bei meinen
jahrelangen rein unterstützung wäre
natürlich auch der mitarbeitern in der
partei auch im ministerium für ihre
arbeit für ihren einsatz für ihre
loyalität und ihren arbeitseinsatz
danken und gerade in dieser schweren
stunde bitte ich bei den vielen bürgern
um verständnis
die mir gestern in unzähligen
telefonaten mails postings den rücken
gestärkt haben und mir rückhalt gegeben
haben das sage danke und wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen tag